this individual is it's small it's
scared it's frail Olivia Gonzalez says
Monday was the first time she was in the
same room as the man accused of killing
her sister Kaylee she told us she was
anxious going in but was surprised to
see him as barely human there wasn't
much that I felt that I had to fear
there it felt very weak the accused
looked Straight Ahead as the judge read
the four murder charges against him
stating he could face the death penalty
for each one do you understand an
accident yes is Mr coburger prepared to
plead to these charges
standing silent has the same legal
effect as entering a not guilty plea CBS
News legal contributor Jessica Levinson
says standing silent could give the
defendant more options amid any possible
plea negotiations